exceptionnel mais j'aimerais expliquer
aux gens qui ne savent pas toujours mais
une chanson c'est un compositeur
quelqu'un qui écrit et un interprète les
plus gros succès d'herbalona ont été
composés par Vladimir Cosma ou Julien
Lepers et puis écrite par d'autres
personnes qu'une chanson qui a été
écrite par Vladimir Cosma oui celle que
tu viens de chanter et tout le reste ça
a été composé pratiquement par voilà ça
veut dire que la scène l'organisation
donne de l'argent à chaque fois que vous
l'entendez quelque part à la radio en
boîte de nuit machin au compositeur et
et celui qui l'a écrit mais vous vous
touchez de l'argent quand vous faites
des concerts ou quand vous vendez des
disques exactement évidemment
aujourd'hui vous faites-moi le concert
un petit peu sur les ventes de disques
en tant qu'interprète mais vraiment un
tout petit peu donc on est bien d'accord
et une fois Dave m'avait dit aussi Dave
m'avait dit si c'est pas mon mon mari
pardon il s'appelle l'oiseau Patrick
Loiseau Patrick je comme je ne peux plus
chanter je n'ai rien j'ai zéro qui tombe
voilà donc c'était quand même ce qu'il
faut le dire donc effectivement comment
on fait est-ce que à l'époque vous avez
conscience de ça et du coup vous mettiez
beaucoup d'argent de côté et aujourd'hui
vous vivez dessus vous êtes fous d'abord
moi je théorise pas d'accord j'avais
décidé avec ma femme de toute la
question on profiterait de la vie ouais
la ligne donc on en a profité donc j'ai
gagné pas mal d'argent j'ai pas dit des
millions des milliards j'ai gagné pas
mal d'argent vous avez gagné des des
millions de francs à l'époque des
millions de francs et j'ai payé beaucoup
d'impôts d'abord bien sûr beaucoup
beaucoup et puis avec le reste j'ai vécu
et je vis encore aujourd'hui avec le
reste les affaires pour en ce qui me
concerne ce sont pratiquement arrêtés au
milieu des années 90 à partir de 95 96
donc on vendait plus de disques enfin
moi je ne suis plus discret là le train
de vie descend d'un coup le train de vie
descend d'un coup évidemment imagine que
c'est difficile mais bon attention je le
dis pour tout le monde je suis pas
malheureux non pas du tout mais c'est
vrai que quand on entend qu'un artiste
comme vous gagne 1500 euros par mois et
qu'en fait ce qui est horrible ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que à partir du
moment où vous ne pouvez plus chanter ce
que vous êtes plus âgé ou qui est un peu
moins de succès tous les autres touches
mais je chante toujours un seul à dire
absolument mais je vends plus
pratiquement plus de bisque parce que
les gens n'achètent plus de disques mais
enfin le CD je veux dire bah oui c'est
mais aujourd'hui justement vous chantez
encore pardon mais pour vivre ou vous en
passeriez quand même un peu oui du
plaisir mais pour vivre
l'argent que j'avais devant moi
quand les choses sont arrêtées un petit
peu enfin quand je suis sorti un peu du
panel que l'argent que j'avais devant
moi mais je le dépense maintenant
d'accord mais je continue à chanter pour
toujours gagner un peu d'argent j'ai une
question et puis de toute manière j'aime
ça alors
on parle de la pénibilité du travail
alors bien sûr il y a des gens qui sont
des déménageurs j'en ai vu à 40 ans ils
ont plus de dos et tout ça et tout ça
mais quand j'avais parié j'ai parlé à
Jacky Lombard qui a la grande tourneuse
des des stars elle me dit Justin Bieber
il est burn out Céline Dion elle monte
plus sur scène on les preste tellement
pour des pour des concerts il y a une
vraie pénibilité aussi les mecs ils sont
rincés est-ce que dans un sens vous
pensez que pour les interprètes comme
vous il aurait pu avoir aujourd'hui vous
allez chanter pardon vous avez une des
problèmes physiques une période de santé
vous avez 78 ans et vous allez chanter
pour gagner votre vie c'est un métier
c'est pas un métier facile oui c'est pas
un métier pénible non plus
c'est juste qu'il faut savoir dès le
début à ceux qui nous regardent mettez
de côté exactement il faut savoir il
faut savoir ce qu'on fait il faut savoir
ne pas aller trop loin je pense que
toutes ces stars que dans Jackie
l'embarbou vous apparaît ce sont des des
stars qui sont pressés comme des citrons
elles n'ont pas une minute à elle ils
font des dépressions prennent pas moi
personnellement j'ai toujours fait la
césure entre mamie professionnelle et ma
vie privée donc j'ai vécu aussi pour ma
vie privée est-ce que je peux me parler
d'une question parce que ça parle
d'argent un peu naturellement
globalement aujourd'hui votre train de
vie c'est quoi 50000 euros par mois
pardon aujourd'hui globalement votre
train de vie c'est quoi 50000 euros par
mois tout à fait normal ça veut dire
quoi
Philippe m'a dit avec 10000 € par mois
retraite vous l'avez dit 3005 de combien
vous avez besoin un peu près pour vivre
correctement on va avec avec 35 je vis
avec 3500
je suis à vous dans une minute parce que
je vous adore c'était tous les samedis
mais attention je n'ai pas bougé ça
c'est juste ma retraite de temps en
temps je chante un peu et je sais bien
et j'ai envie d'aller vous voir parce
que je sais aussi qu'il y a une il y a
je dis l'autre jour que c'était 3500 je
crois que ce même un peu moins que ça je
peux vous demander quelque chose
là c'est un peu perso vous faites des
concerts privés
amoureux fou un truc comme ça
[Rires]
Daniel oui pourquoi ça vous agace vous
avez dit ça c'est Jordan vous avez dit
c'était pas que pour vous mais ça
m'agace en ce moment en pleine en pleine
crise des retraites où les gens ne
peuvent plus bouffer ne peuvent plus
rééduquer leurs enfants ça m'agace de
voir ces stars qui ont gagné des
millions et qu'on passe sous les gérer
bah venir se plaindre non c'est pas que
ça m'agace mais moi quand on me pose la
question c'est ce que j'ai dit à Jordan
je lui ai dit combien on te paye pour me
poser la question mais vous allez voir
vous avez dit c'est indécent ces gens
qui viennent je trouve que c'est un
dessin quand on a la chance d'être dans
des métiers où il y a des hauts et des
bas mais qui sont des métiers tellement
tellement ludiques c'est une telle
chance quelle que soit le métier moi moi
j'estime que j'ai beaucoup de chance
sinon j'aurais été professeur et par
hasard j'ai été élu par été spectateurs
en Auvergne et je me retrouve ce soir
avec beaucoup de plaisir c'est très
gentil mais par exemple
[Applaudissements]
grand actrice sous le soleil du théâtre
les trois frères je fais pas votre CV
sinon on finit à 22h beaucoup de talents
mais c'est vrai que vous aussi vous avez
annoncé très honnêtement une retraite
aux alentours de 1500 euros je crois
aujourd'hui et puis alors oui il y a pas
de SACEM il y a rien vous c'est juste
que quand vous travaillez pas vous êtes
pas payé et on a en plus ce problème
pardon dont on parle pas mais quand on
est une femme au cinéma c'est vrai aussi
on vous donne moins de rôle mais
c'est-à-dire de moins en moins oui moins
en moins c'est clair
la vie s'arrête à 45 ans à l'image
c'était il y a très très peu de rôles
c'est ce que j'ai dit chez Jordan aussi
on n'est pas dans chez les anglo-saxons
où il y a des maguis Smiths
des gens comme ça nous ici non on peut
pas on n'a pas le vous avez mis beaucoup
de côté justement avant vous avez mis
beaucoup de côtés
je sais pas à l'époque de sous le soleil
c'était le grand grand truc c'était en
France on parlait de 50000 francs par
mois c'était à peu près ça ah non non
pas du tout pas du tout je ne sais pas
je ne suis pas dans le portefeuille de
mes camarades qui étaient avec moi et
qui étaient les héroïnes de la série
mais moi j'étais pas du tout ça non mais
je gagnais très correctement ma vie et
comme je suis une petite fourmi
voilà vous avez vous aviez prévu vous
avez prévu que ça pourrait être
compliqué mais dans le cas de Philippe
par exemple c'est intéressant c'est
Daniel vous dites mais Philippe est très
intéressant
non je ne suis pas Karine Lemarchand et
j'ai vraiment passé la date de
péremption
entre nous il y a pas de télé donc on
peut
[Rires]
toutes les femmes sont belles
mais non arrêtez avec ça arrêtez avec là
j'ai la beauté intérieure alors ça
compte ah bon hein toi tu as tout alors
la beauté intérieure la beauté
extérieure
mais Philippe ces personnes ça donne de
l'espoir aussi parce qu'en fait moi je
vois c'est des gens que j'ai connu quand
j'étais tout gamin ils sont encore
aujourd'hui en train de vivre de leur
passion
par exemple tu as vu midi première avec
ton arrière-grand-mère tout ça pour me
donner le moral
non mais vous nous avez inspiré
[Applaudissements]
en fait qu'on va pas pouvoir patiner
jusqu'à 60 ans et d'autres sportifs
c'est là où l'aspect social si on avait
un statut sur les sportifs de haut
niveau et comme pour les artistes alors
l'intermittence de spectacle a permis
aussi de faire progresser un petit peu
cette tu veux dire que dans votre cas il
faudrait commencer à comme pour le
danseur étoile dans un toile sur votre
38 ans vous devriez avec ma fille qui a
été danseuse à l'Opéra qui a fait les
petits rats en fait ils sont pas payés
tant qu'ils ont pas 18 ans mais le le
l'opéra cotise à l'URSSAF pour les
gamines contre d'accord et 17 ans c'est
pour ça que les danseurs étoiles à 32
ans arrive en fait à une carrière pleine
de trimestre et c'est pour ça qu'ils
peuvent partir à la retraite à cet
âge-là et vous comprenez le sport non
c'est bien dommage et vous comprenez
quand même que pour les gens qui nous
regardent eux ils ont une retraite ils
ont eu un salaire je sais pas de 2000
3000 € toute leur vie les Florent Pagny
il est tout ça et les nanas même si il y
a beaucoup payé d'impôts il y a eu des
années à trois quatre cinq dix millions
d'euros quand on a gagné autant d'argent
on n'a pas même si après la retraite est
à 1000 balles on peut pas on peut pas
venir à la télé et dire ce que je dis
n'est pas malheureux on a pas le droit
de toute façon
il a gagné des millions pendant le match
il fallait pas rouler
en Porsche malheureusement
[Rires]
non j'ai mis j'ai pensé en fait à
l'avenir effectivement nous a toujours
dit vous les sportifs ça sont la
retraite vous n'en n'aurez pas donc il
fallait mettre de côté et puis encore
une fois quand on est quand même pas
venu pour se plaindre non
c'est vous qui nous faites venir manger
c'est que déjà je veux juste faire
comprendre aux gens qui vous ont
agressés sur les réseaux que déjà aussi
quand vous étiez jeune et tout ça il
faut un agent pour vous éduquer il faut
qu'on vous explique tout ça à zéro on
pense pas on pense pas à tous moi j'ai
l'impression moi je vais vous dire autre
chose
parce que c'est surtout Christine vous
vous êtes fait Mary Christine pardon sur
les réseaux ça oui oui mais il y a une
méchanceté
je ne suis pas moi non plus ça vous a
touché ça oui parce que moi je suis
quelqu'un de très discret et plutôt
plutôt voilà donc j'ai pas très bien
compris ça mais c'est les réseaux
sociaux je crois que il y a beaucoup de
jalousies
vous demandez à berce que si c'est pas
indiscret toute cette réforme des
retraites vous aujourd'hui les gens dans
la rue tout ça ce que vous en pensez
j'ai pas compris
non non c'est moi qui m'exprime mal
toutes ces réformes des retraites en ce
moment les gens qui sont dans la rue
qu'est-ce que ça veut évoque chez vous
est-ce que vous êtes plutôt des côtés
des gens est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut faire cette retraite et je pense
que si Macron était intelligent
il opterait pour le référendum parce
qu'il n'y a que ça qui compte il n'y a
que le peuple qui décide c'est pas
Macron qui dessine pas déconner
non mais c'est pas mal
je vais me faire descendre sur les
réseaux sociaux
je répète toujours ça mais on n'est
jamais quand on est sincère tout passe
et ce qui est un peu d'ailleurs comme
dans votre métier
c'est le public qui vient vous voir en
concert on peut on peut vendre les
places qu'on veut si ils veulent pas
quand le public le décide ouais une
chanson on ne crée pas de tue on le
compose pas du tube bien sûr chanson
devient un tube si le public le veut et
vous marie-christie
et vous non Daniel Daniel qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ça moi ce que j'en pense
c'est que je pense que quand on a le
costume de gouvernants en général on a
on doit être intelligent c'est vrai
l'intelligence qu'on acquiert quand on
quand on s'instruit mais il y a une
partie de l'intelligence
à laquelle on peut pas échapper et qui
je pense que je suis très démodé de ce
côté là c'est l'intelligence de
l'intuition et de l'empathie et ça si on
n'a pas ça on peut pas faire un truc on
ne peut pas faire des choses pour tout
le monde qu'avec des chiffres on peut
pas
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire ah oui
que vous êtes d'accord je veux dire que
il faut pas mettre on peut pas mettre
que des chiffres d'accord et puis
imposer les choses d'accord vous savez
quoi ça me fait penser la France ça me
fait penser à un grand ring de boxe
alors attention parce que pas
complètement d'accord avec vous même
avec Herbère
cette loi elle avait été décidé lors de
la dernière présidentielle quand on dit
démocratie les français pour un mec ça
voulait Macron qui avait dit qu'il était
65 au départ désolé 64 bien sûr
ce vote là il est il est il a plus de
valeur au moins de valeur que des gens
dans la rue on est en démocratie en
français
parce que les gens savaient pas
exactement
parce que je vous en remercie vous êtes
très honnête et vous en parler vous m'ar
difficile aussi pareil aujourd'hui ça va
bien pour vous mais qu’est-ce que vous
pensez vous voyez bien l'état de la
France aujourd'hui bien sûr est-ce que
vous pensez que cette réforme est juste
moi je pense que oui les gens c'est à
dire qu'il y a tels injustices je veux
dire au niveau en plus c'est très
compliqué Daniel le disait ça a été très
très mal expliqué je pense qu'il y a des
gens qui sont lésés vraiment lésés parce
que à cause de la pénibilité etc nous on
fait un métier de passion donc ok on est
blessé quand on travaille pas peut-être
nos égaux etc mais les gens il y a des
gens qui a 60 ans ils en peuvent plus
donc et toutes ces trucs on n'y connaît
rien pardon moi je n'y connais rien en
tout cas je ne veux pas mettre les
autres mais c'est très nébuleuse ce truc
là et tout d'un coup on fait un 49-3 et
on nous dit bah voilà c'est comme ça
j'ai découvert grâce à TPMP je le redis
je suis très fier de cette émission
parce que j'ai découvert des choses
quand il y a eu le scandale total et qui
est plus d'essence dans Paris que les
gens qui travaillent dans des
raffineries
17 ans d'espérance de vie en moins ça
veut dire qu'il y a un monsieur qui se
réveille le matin et pour faire bouffer
ses enfants il a accepté de vivre 7 ans
de moins écoutez moi j'ai mon père il a
il a été éboueur mais attention pas les
bouilleurs juste qui ramassent les
ordures dans la rue un vrai éboueur qui
allait dans les trucs de fumier enfin
tous tout ce qui se nettoyer quoi bah il
a pris sa retraite à 60 ans et il est
mort à 63 ans voilà c'est tout
qui sont dans ce cas là absolument moi
ce que je pense de façon beaucoup plus
générale sur l'humain c'est que chaque
personne quelle qu'elle soit a besoin de
reconnaissance et qu'on s'intéresse à
elle d'ailleurs ce Ludovic je pense que
vous voyez qui sait Ludovic le l'éboueur
qui avait un chapeau rouge une tenue
verte il a mis l'accent sur le fait que
quand finalement on se rend compte que
les éboueurs c'est un travail très
important pour notre vie et combien de
fois combien de gens se sont intéressés
à eux ça c'est vrai donc il faut chacun
pour le bon sens et je suis pour le
respect de l'autre alors Philippe soit
aussi bien président de la République
éboueur qu'autre chose
à ceux qui nous écoutent que la France
et le pays qui a le plus d'aide qui
pardon
au Portugal
je vous arrête tout s'il vous plaît ah
dans cette émission on fait pas de
politique et de les gens qui crèvent de
ça en France ça leur fait une belle
jambe de savoir ce qui se passe dans
l'espace je veux dire franchement
Philippe j'ai une question à te poser
s'il te plaît d'accord là-dessus le seul
problème c'est que cette proposition de
de réforme de retraite les gens n'en
veulent pas et ben pourquoi là mais pas
à la poubelle et qu'on en refait l'autre
parce qu'on en reste économiquement ça
marche pas il y a plus de gens qui
partent à la retraite aujourd'hui qui
vieillissent
et que quand vous dites on nous a pas
expliqué sauf que les gens veulent pas
entendre et que les oppositions sont pas
non plus là pour expliquer
quelque chose aussi pardon tout le monde
n'a pas fait 50 ans d'études il y a des
gens qui ont assez et qui comprennent
pas tout ce qu'on leur explique on n'est
pas toujours fini j'aimerais un mot non
non j'aimerais juste d'abord Philippe et
après je te jure toi mais Philippe ça
m'intéresse parce que vous venez d'un
milieu modeste euh vous avez perdu votre
je crois de votre pas en plus 64 ans à
64 ans pareil non mais c'est ça ce qui
est intéressant de comprendre aussi
c'est que aujourd'hui on entend que Miyu
modeste 64 ans milieu modeste 63 ans
mais non mais pardon Laurent elle est là
la réalité aussi elle est là la réalité
c'est ce que tu penses des retraites moi
je pense de toute façon déjà c'est vrai
que ceux qui ont 60 ans ou 59 et qui
apprennent qui vont devoir travailler 2
ans de plus alors qu'ils étaient préparé
totalement
cela ils partiront à 60 et 62 c'est la
réforme beaucoup de fake news beaucoup
de trucs qui sont faux
non c'est pas déjà politique non mais
c'est pas vrai quoi c'est pas des gens
qui sont préparé à partir là et qui ont
dit vous allez faire deux ans de plus il
y en a il y en a c'est qui ça c'est 75
donc c'est pas déjà politique c'est que
les people je trouve ça très très bien
ce que vous faites aujourd'hui bah
pardon souvent ce thèse lorsque
lorsqu'il faut voter lorsqu'il faut 10
et parfois il parle et parfois ils
disent qu'ils ont sur le cœur et je
trouve que vous le dites et c'est très
bien et c'est très courageux Isabelle
alors moi ça me fait quand même mal au
calme pour le coup moi je suis dans une
radio
où tous les matins
tous les matins on a fait un travail on
a expliqué cette réforme qu'elle soit
bonne ou mauvaise elle a été très mal
expliquée et tous les matins on a fait
un travail de simplification en
répondant aux questions des auditeurs
moi ça me fait mal au cœur quand
j'entends dire mais tout le monde
n'écoute pas si tu reprises sur les
réseaux sociaux partout étant excuse-moi
elle a pardonne-moi mais effectivement
il a fait un vrai travail didactique
formidable d'accord en ce qui concerne
les éboueurs moi c'est vraiment un
métier que je trouve absolument
extraordinaire mais quand on a vu toutes
les poubelles dans la rue qu'on dit les
gens ils ont pas dit c'est là
qu'on voit à quel point ce travail
important ils ont dit quand est-ce qu'on
va nous enlever ces merdes donc il faut
aussi que chacun balai devant sa porte
exceptionnel mais tu le ferais pas
on va protéger Mathieu
chaque fois que j'ouvre un bidon toi
chaque fois que j'ouvre ma poubelle je
me dis et voilà je me débarrasse de mon
problème est-ce que vous voulez est-ce
que vous pensez à tous et c'est très
important et c'est pour ça que vous êtes
là aussi est-ce que vous pensez parce
que vous avez du poids vous êtes connu
vous êtes des célébrités est-ce que vous
pensez alors maintenant c'est passé mais
il y a quand même on sait que il peut y
avoir encore une comment s'appelle une
notion qui peut être qui peut être
déposé est-ce que vous pensez que votre
votre avis ce que vous dites peut avoir
un poids ou on s'en fout complètement
mais moi je cherche pas à avoir un poids
à quel point je m'arrache les cheveux
[Rires]
je pense que ça se passe au niveau
politique
c'est entre le LR et les macronistes
alors c'est autre chose à vous demander
du coup parce que c'est là que c'est là
que je trouve pas très juste et je
voulais lui demander l'autre jour à
Spain qui était là et j'ai raté ma
question parce qu'il était pas là smiley
il paraît plein de choses de l'Algérie
de machin de nanas Julie c'est
formidable tu me parles de plein de
choses à ça mais quand il les élections
qui a eu Zemmour qui a eu machin on t'a
pas entendu et là quand il y a eu toutes
les élections et vous en parlez des
réformes des retraites des machins
c'était peut-être avant qu'il fallait
entendre vos voix et qu'elles aient eu
une importance pourquoi vous n'avez pas
parlé avant les élections tous
c'est pas une critique non non je sens
qu'il me regarde
c'est pas une critique mais franchement
on n'est pas obligé de mélanger parce
que vous habitez
personne ne m'invite plus personne ne
vous invite plus partie du passé
monsieur mais monsieur à partir de ce
soir vous dormez à la maison vous dormez
chez moi personne ne vous invite plus
voilà parfait parce que je rigole 3
secondes mais vraiment vraiment vous
n'avez pas idée mais je sais pas si vous
avez idée mais Marie-Christine vous
Herbère de ce que peut créer on a tous à
retour à l'enfance quand je vous vois je
me vois mais samedi devant la télévision
et quand je vous vois et que je sais les
chansons que j'ai aimé c'est beaucoup
d'émotions et continuer non mais bien
sûr mais c'est bon
pour mon émission
il y avait des Claude François
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]